hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
the cytobank solution a cytometry data
sharing platform
for collaborative multicentric data
analysis
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckman culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
eric
director of the immunophenotyping corps
of thief
dr lush you may now begin your
presentation
many thanks for this kind introduction
and good morning hello everyone
so i'm gonna present you this webinar on
the cytobank solution and how we
use it at the center of immunophenomics
to drive
our collaborative multicentric data
analysis
the first disclaimer that this
presentation is sponsored by beckmann
culter and that the
content is scientific non-promotional
and educational
and that the views are actually mine not
uh
not controlled by a batman culture and
that beckman cuter does not accept any
responsibility or liability for the
accuracy
content completely legality reliability
of the information presented here
the first slide that i wanted to to to
show is this one is it's to my view the
core elements of the cytobac
cytobank platform and why it's of
interest to to all of us
first it's a biologist friendly
interface so you don't need any
bioinformatics skills to actually
use it and drive you and write your
analysis
next you can do a data
sharing and also analysis sharing which
is very interesting
we will see how we can do that uh it
include tools for data pre-processing
which
sometimes is a bit tricky to to to
master on other platforms
and you have embedded machine learning
algorithm and and this most of the time
is actually what
what is being presented and put up front
in webinars
i'm not gonna do that today because i
want to show i would like to show you
uh the the the powerful of the interface
in terms of
um of uh organization of the experiment
as well as
uh the the illustration that you can
build with this solution
so that you can build efficient
visualization of multi-group data set
and also that the the cytobank platform
allows for integration of
data partition meaning clustering
generated by algorithm that may be not
present in cytobank platform but you can
still use to actually
visualize your data on it and very
importantly
it's a tool that allows you to keep an
eye on your sales scale
which is important for investigation of
the the quality of the clustering and
partition of your data
because sometimes you really you you
really need to look you you might have
some
some difficulties there and finally you
can extract statistical table with a
large panel of metrics that could be
useful for you
for your project so let's start first
with um
with the presentation of where i'm
working so that you understand better
why we went to adopt this solution
at civ so what we basically do is is
cytometry in all kinds so flow of
spectral
mass as well as genomic cytometry and
the idea of what we do is to actually
immunoprofile the immune system of
mostly mouse models in different
settings
in disease immune oncology it could be
inflammation or infection to better
understand
how the immune system is perturbed in
presence of a challenge
and also our treatment candidate could
actually
improve a clinical outcome
one example is uh mc38 it's a tumor
model
so we could do a clinical efficacy like
a lot of labs do but what we really
put our efforts is is actually
extracting cells immune cells from
different organs
lymphoid organs as well as tumor mass
and use the different technology we have
uh acif
to actually immune profile in depth the
immune system
so and then experiment could look like
this with different panels
and really the goal of this is to be
able to do this
analysis in unsupervised manner
try to be as descriptive as possible to
identify populations
and then next is to actually correlate a
change in density of population
uh that correlates with uh treatment
uh and obviously a treatment efficacy
like what we see here
uh we see that those um at
a very high dose of this xxy treatment
we see a complete change of the immune
profile that we would see with isotype
control
and to do this actually we we we work uh
fully uh
in a panel that is done at sif or we
actually work with um
externalization of our panels that's
possible in mass cytometry
uh from this technology published in in
cytometry
the idea that is that we we combine
interactions so we send our panels to
our partner they use them
in their workflow and then send us back
stain cells and then we do the analysis
for them and then you start to
understand why we need cytobank for
the data analysis and raw data need to
be analyzed by us but
shared by our distant partners and we'll
see how we do that
what we also use cytobank for is to
project our
in-house analysis capabilities to
partner side so we have in-house a suite
of different tools
uh for pre-processing dimensionality
reduction in clustering annotation
and we use cytobank to visualize and
reach fcs file and i will come into
in a minute how we do that so the site
of bank to
platform usage is this is ready to be
able to
to project our analysis capabilities to
distant partners
uh to also do remote validation of newly
generated data sets so
if i have my collaborator generating
data sets i can have a look at the data
through cytobank and also give advice on
the analysis
perspective we can use cytobank to
visualize results of data partitioning
check with our clustering when okay
we can visualize results of very quickly
of multi-group multi-sample data
set and interrogate on the fly that i
said during that
collaborative data reviews we will see
that
and also we we can use meta data tags
with
which is very important to actually
organize
outlayouts illustration on cytobank
so now if i go in in the different part
of
the the platform i would like to
showcase today i will first talk about
the experiment manager because it's a
nice way to organize your data
to actually show
slides sorry to actually show that i
will use a
data set that we have generated
throughout a consortium which is cell
failure
self-advising infrastructure is actually
an alliance of four research
centers that have complementary
expertise in animal experimentation
so the thief is there from his mouse
expertise but we have a center that is
really focused on on
right immuno phenotyping knowledge that
we don't have but we have um
there is another site like us anira uh
who is trained for advanced data
analysis methodology so the idea is
really to join forces to
to push immunophenotyping within this
consortium but for this you need to have
a plan and especially a plan on how to
organize your data and that's what we
did on cytobank
uh using a dedicated license for the
self
fed failure work and and to to sum up
the big challenge
uh we had it was the data management
because uh
within this project the pastel project
we had several working package
and each of each time we needed to share
data
and analyze this so that we can draw on
conclusion in
a collaborative manner and that has been
difficult because we don't have at the
consortium level
a night infrastructure next we also need
to work along the fair principle which
are
findability accessibility intel
interoperability and reuse of digital
data sets
and for this we need to we needed to
find a solution and cytobank for us
was the best available and and then how
to share raw data sets and corresponding
analysis in a curated sociable manner
and then cytomec was very good for that
why because we could basically define
labels to actually tag
all of our several experiments so to
recall
in this consortium we deal with mouse
and rust immunophenotyping we have flow
and mass cytometry data set
there are four work packages there are
some experiments that are designed for
setup
and order for actually analysis of
samples
that we need to to deliver results for
so you need organization and we did this
through this sequential so you you in
in cytobank you have the capacity to put
labels
like like you you see here um
that's uh you can you can create a new
label
like here i created one disney and
tagged
to experiment with the disney label so
that i can use
that later on for my
investigation of the data sets
then next what i can do is basically use
quickly this filter
so if i go on for example here uh
bi i can actually filter all the
experiments that have this label
and show them in the interface so that
like this is very efficient
to find an experiment that has been
stored on cytobank
and and that's why we needed this common
language for the consortium so that
everyone can use
these tags to to draw go go through the
dataset very efficiently
next once you have selected an
experiment you come to this window which
is
an experimental detail of of the
experiment and what is there so you see
that we have an experiment summary with
the different labels we also have a part
where we see illustrations that have
been
developed fcs file included into this
experiment so
we see here android 56 it's a lot so you
need you need a plan to visualize data
from that
and then we have attachment and i wanted
to draw
our attention that in the attachments
you can put illustration results or pdf
and images
but you can also put all related
documents to the experiments like
sop papers describing the work that is
being done in the experiment or
a sum up as a pptx format uh for
to actually show the results um and and
and basically you put in all these
attachments
within the experiment so that everyone
is at the same page in terms of
information about this experiment that's
very powerful
next is sharing right shuttle cytobank
platform is is a tool
a collaborative tool in a sense because
you can create your experiment
uh set it up with like this labels do
illustration but then you can share it
with your colleagues
and and this takes just a simple click
so when you go to the to the sharing
part
of the of the the interface like shown
here with the
red arrow then you can just select the
username of your of your collaborator
and once you've done that instantly will
have access to all the work and
documents that
you have associated to to the experiment
which is uh which is very fantastic
next you you can also share a different
privilege level
and this goes through the use of a
project and definition of a project
so to to set sharing privilege you need
to create a
project and then you have access to this
window where you actually can define
project members
as managers so they have all rights to
modify and
do whatever on the experiment level
leaders
that have a little less right they can
share uh
inclu and and clone experiment uh and
members
members can only visualize data they
cannot modify anything
so that was for the experimental manager
part
now i wanted to highlight few things
about the gating editor
to show you that it's just not about
gating
so the interface within cytobank is
actually
powerful for other things so first how
it
does it looks like so that's the gating
editor interface
we see that there are several windows or
several interaction box
one shows for example the gating tool so
that's quite common and of what you can
use as a tool for getting your data you
have a way
below to change the analysis variable
x y and also z depending on the plot
type you select the red box
and then you can either define gates
um on the on the orange box on ungated
data
or your chain you can change the parent
population and then set a gate on this
parent population
so that's that's very nice so you can
get this uh
from scratch but uh very importantly you
can also upload
historical gating strategies uh from
previous experiments you did inside the
bank using the exact same panel
uh by this simple button import gate
that we see on the on the
on the header of this uh this interface
but we also can
importantly use gating ml which is the
standard that has been
defined by isaac to actually
allow data curation across different
platforms different softwares
and also uh this is a stone that has
been being understandable by
bioinformatician
using r so it's really key that allows
you to basically validate results that
unsupervised analysis may have done
on a traditional gating strategy
and all this is is possible through
sitelink now the other nice thing about
cytobank
is the data scaling it's very important
to do that because if you don't
set your scales around zero correctly
you might have issues at dimensionality
reduction
techniques because basically the
algorithm we'll see for example if we
see
axinus h without any transformation you
see very
popul some cells that are very negative
and some cells that appear dim and some
cells of that api actually so it's a
transformation
artifact but the algorithm will will
separate that into
different population which are
artifactual so you really need to set
scales
and that's why when you create a new
experiment in cytobank solution
uh the first step that one needs to what
that one is asking you
is to adjust scale that's very critical
and you need to do that
so but what i wanted to highlight here
is that
the scaling tool within the cytobank
interface is very
easy to use and also cope with different
data types so flow mass spectral and
genomics so you can scale all these data
types with the transformation including
in the tool
and you can also work on data from
different flow cytometers so we tested
several ones because we do benchmark of
flow cytometers
also as one of our activities and we we
actually checked all data types produced
by different instruments on the market
and they will always be
you could always analyze them on cytomeg
omega scale them properly there
next what i wanted to show you is a very
very cool
possibility that is to be able to derive
gates from enriched parameters or
cluster parameters
so for example here we have single cell
genomic data set i'm looking at umap
dimensions um and what i would like to
do
is basically here i project erphenograph
data
so that has been enriched into another
software and not available in cytobank
but i can
i can visualize that and then i see my
color code that fits to cluster
annotation
but what i would like to do is to to
calculate frequencies of cell within
each of these clusters so for this
i can create an automatic cluster gate
by pressing here selecting my dimension
where i have the cluster information
erphenograph for example here and then
apply these changes
and automatically a phenograph will
segment the data based on the
attribution of each single cell to this
given cluster
and that's really powerful because now i
can use that
for subsequent analysis in the same time
it creates population
that are all uh regroup all cells
belonging to each of the clusters
and here i have the identification in
this cluster table
i can look at the frequencies uh using
the population tree
and see what's the weight relative
weight of each of these
in my sample and then i can also
visualize it for
something like very much this
visualization for sunburst
that shows you the different proportion
a relative proportion of each cluster
but i can even push further i can also
split my file so in it i had two
groups bazel and inflamed so i can
actually
use that sample flag that is included in
my fcs
to actually create new new files
so for example here and that's how i can
clone an experiment and then here on the
bottom
i see i can select populations
and i will select the population that
relates to my
sample flags and what cytobank will do
is basically
split the files into and allow me to
investigate the same gating strategy or
the same thing i've been doing before
and then visualize the results and like
this very graphically i can see
that in my in-flame condition i have
this cluster
in gray that is increased and the
cluster six that is decreased in my
in-flame group and then i can directly
relate it to percentage so graphically
it's very very powerful and efficient
um then what i can also do
so i have kind of already shown that in
cytobank you have these machine learning
tools that are
embedded are actually already integrated
interface
which are flowsome and you also have
disney you you have
additionally spade and citrus so all
these tools
you can use in cytobank but you know the
the pace
of the algorithm development is is is
really fast
uh and they are basically every month a
new method that comes out so
how do you do to actually still use this
nice tool that is cytobank
uh with the with these new uh methods
that comes
uh well that's what we did uh at sif
basically
uh we we we see if we can um
take the fcs file that has been analyzed
first in cytobank
cytobank put the new coordinates for
clusters and also
dimensionality reduction into new
parameters so it
enrich the fcs file with this
information and then i can use these
files
to do another analysis like here
scaffold and then once this is done
information from this new method is
enriching the fcs file and i can log it
back to cytobank and do a final
visualization and share that to my
colleagues
so that that's that's something really
important we do
we do it safe just hear about the
concept
of uh fcs file enrichment so that you
understand well
so you start with your matrix of
parameters
uh where you actually have each line of
cell each colon a parameter
and then the value measured from the
from the instrument
uh what you can think of doing is a
dimensionality reduction
using these variables here and then
what your software most most of the time
do is that you can
actually compute this and then integrate
the new information into the original
data matrix
so you enrich it with either
dimensionality reduction coordinates
or clustering like flow sum here
and then once this is done you can add
more and more do more clustering and
each time
section sequentially enrich your fcs
file the really cool thing is that each
of these
new parameters are available for
cytobank to be
used for visualization or like what i
showed you before
splitting data or creating population
from this new dimension so
it basically increased drastically uh
the capacity of what you can do
uh using your your cytometry analysis
then the end gate end goal is always a
visualization on cytobank
because of the capacity to keep the cell
uh the cell level cellular level so you
you can project your information at the
cellular level
and that helps you to actually qc your
data in the clustering steps
here it's another example of that we did
in cytobank so
it's we we projected airphenograph
cluster
clustering results onto onto a
disney map actually it's a not sne map
so something you cannot do now uh on
cytobank but you can use the
visualization
uh techniques that are embedded in it
and that's very efficient
now let's shift to uh something that is
super cool
uh very important for me it's the
illustration mode
because there is you know when you have
android 56 files and you need to analyze
that in
a comprehensive manner and share the
information to your colleagues
you need something else than just
conventional flow cytometry software
and this is what what cytobank really
brings us
so that's an example here of an
experiment immuno phenotyping of several
inbred strains and and
and mutant mice on these given back
genetic backgrounds so they have 16
different
uh different backgrounds and
yeah and then starts uh what to do with
that so first of the thing
you should think about doing is actually
to annotate your data with sample tags
that's very important because that's the
powerful
the power actually of what you could do
in terms of on
analyze this later on it's coming from
that
so for example uh you can do that
manually and i actually i
have put the link of the manual
annotation here
but you can also do that automatically
so the easiest way
i wanted to show you is for this so you
can first go into
export sample tags then you have the the
predefined tables that cytobanks use to
actually encode the different conditions
um
that are available in in the platform at
start
and then you can basically create your
own tag
and re-upload that sample tag uh
into the the the platform and then have
access to it so it's a very convenient
way
when you have um a lot of files for 16
but when you have a plate for example
to be able to annotate your your full
data set
in one in one click
then what you basically have is uh
you use this sample tag next to actually
drive your illustration design so
uh in cytobank illustration mode
you have different boxes and here it's
the
sample tag box and you see that i have
set up
condition tags that actually i use that
to
put the information about the mutation
that i'm looking at
i have tags about experiments because
that has been acquired across two
experiments and then i have group tags
for the genetic background so like this
i can
basically filter using these tags i can
filter my data set and only show a part
of it so what i'm showing here although
i had
newton's on by c background and
nmri background i have filtered all
the all the other mice and i'm only
keeping the one that are on the b6
background and then i am showing all the
mutants that were acquired on this b6
background and then you see nicely the
results so
it's very very convenient to actually
adjust what you want to show
on an illustration using these these
tags and
i've seen a lot of people not using this
capacity and i think it's a big mistake
that's that's a very powerful
functionality of the platform
another example i wanted to bring
for this webinar is actually the
capacity to change
the statistic that is being shown on an
illustration
very quickly like you have one question
you're you are reviewing data with your
collaborator over teleconference
and then someone asked suddenly uh yeah
but so you you showing here a percentage
of
interferon gamma producing cells in the
different in these different
populations but how many cells you
actually have how does it relate into
cell counts so
usually um traditional approach you will
need a secondary analysis you will
exchange with your colleagues
back and forth and then and then solve
this question here in cytobank directly
over the tc you can basically
um change from percentage to event
counts
and then directly the results are
actually
drawn onto your illustration so it saves
you time
on these finicky details
and and allows you to move forward into
your hypothesis
building that that actually distill a
conference needs to be
it needs to be a time where we share
information
and where we actually can make
proposition to move the project forwards
and and that's
what i really liked about about the use
of cytobank in this way
uh over collaborative tc we may have
active
the last thing i wanted to show is
because i i've seen lots of colleagues
that don't do that too so if i can bring
that
there are ways to save your illustration
so you you can really
design several different uh
illustrations that you plan to show to
your colleagues
you can save them and then show them
late for
later during a tc or allow your partners
to actually
go and consume this visualization that
you have prepared
for them you can also use templates so
if you are very fan of one
given a visualization way you can
actually uh
click on a button and then automatically
the template will be applied to your
data set so
it saves you time in in doing if you are
doing over and over again the same kind
of
analysis template illustration then you
can you can do that
very quickly through this capacity
then for example you can like this
create
high quality figures for example here i
project my
marker expression onto this knee map to
check
where are my steady force expressing
cells my cd5 expressing cell my cdx
expressing cell so it's a mass cytometry
data set
then i can do also panorama very quickly
by actually
improving increasing the list of markers
i want to look at and so that also i
don't get lost i can
order that by alphabetical order or
whatever order i want by a
simple click and and drag
action on this window and and again
that's something
seems to very very um little but
it is really uh make this uh
picture this global picture a lot more
readable
from start and the final thing
you can do a basically a crosstalk
because between different visualization
for example here i have one question i
have made clusters
i can visualize the expression of
markers on
heat map inside the bank and then i can
also
project this information onto a disney
map so that i can relate
where are my cells that express this and
this marker
this could be the cell type and then i
relate that to a density
plot that is shown on the upper part of
this figure
and that's basically linking this free
visualization that allows you to have an
understanding of what's going on in your
in your sample and to drive this
information efficiently to your partners
what i also wanted to show you is that
the tags they are not limited so
basically if you want to create a new
one you have the possibility to do that
through this add button
and then you basically create your new
category and then you can
order your fcs file based on this new
uh nomenclature that you are creating
for example here
i created a metal barcoding tag so that
i can encode each file
corresponding to each debug coded or
barcode
that i was using mass cytometry to
encode my samples
and then i can visualize whether the
debug barcoding was okay
or if it's okay i should see always free
yellow box and then three black box so
like this i can have a feel
about the quality of the barcoding and
that's particularly important if
if the work that is being done is
actually um done over several people
so you might have an operator that do
the the the
barcoding and and someone else that
takes into
a responsibility the advanced analysis
uh so
you need to to to have some ways to
check that everything went fine
uh at start and the data set you're
analyzing and that's one way we do it
safe to to check that the barcoding was
okay
so you see you can drive this it must
very very
simply by changing the plot type to heat
map
and then you can also display different
kind of metrics
so here i did a ratio i took the minimum
of the colon and then i apply
i showed the mean of the channel's
variation like this so
you can change all this so it's it's
very easy to actually change
the way the heat map looks depending on
your question
so next what i wanted to show you is
another usage we have at thief
i have a bioinformatician i have
bioinformatician people that do
develop new methodologies so for example
here they are working on
on using deep learning to actually
annotate samples
so they are building different deep
learning models to annotate
the same data sets and we compare that
to a a
data set that was annotated with the
scaffold algorithm
and what you can see here is that each
time i'm projecting either
the cluster identity from scaffold or
from other ones that were given by the
the perceptron that they use in these
deep learning models
so that was uh showing total cells i can
now select because i if i have done it
before
uh i can identify my neutrophils uh by
conventional gating and then
i can show only the cells that are
within this population
in my plot and see whether the
annotation uh is homogeneous or whether
i have one annotation one method that
does not
do a good job so here we see it's it's
time blue so it's each time the same
type of cluster id that is being shown
so
i have a equivalent resolution
of about my methods but this annotation
on neutrophils
now if i look on t cells i see i have
several color
well that's fine because cd4 t cells
have different functional
uh functional subset and they could be
set into different clusters
but to investigate that i need to change
the dimension i'm looking at the tiffany
are not good enough so
i can very intuitively change it on this
axis now in the new interface of
cytobank
and dynamically i can adjust what i see
and i can see
whether the clustering is performing
okay or
how actually this work has been done by
the algorithm and you can
already see um through this way
that scaffold for example is not
segregating the data like
perceptron models that they do more
defined based on on the training data
set they do more defined thresholds on
the data
but that's basically one way so you can
have your bioinformatician
that load new data sets new that newly
analyzed datasets onto cytobank
and then like this way allow you to
actually visualize
and qc what is being done and bring your
biologist
perspective onto the new methods so that
you can improve
improve the results of these new new
methodologies
right so that's very nice way to to to
work between
two um expertise right by
bioinformatician and biologist
i have to say that there is an api that
we don't use asif but
that allowed also by information to run
analysis on cytobank
directly from r
then the final things i wanted to show
is more on
how to to actually use cytobank to
export data so it's not only a
visualization
interface you can actually export a lot
of
different descriptive statistics that
are embedded
within the tool um and
i wanted to show how to do that and also
how we we can use this
advantage of the um
having a figure that or an illustration
that is driven by
um sample tags to actually very quickly
generate a figure for
for in the publication quality and
format
whose site turbine so for the results ex
the export of the result table with the
sample tags basically you go at this
position in the interface so export
export statistics
then you come on this window where you
basically can select
if you want to add a statistic or sample
tags or keywords
into the table of results what type of
statistics you want to export and there
are
a lot of them if you want to export that
on the segment on or some population and
what is the parent population so
you can define all that and then each
time it will add columns
onto your table of results then you can
export that
it comes into a basically an extra a
csv spreadsheet that you can open to
excel
and uh what we basically do at sif is
that we can
we just build a very quickly uh an excel
table and then use pivot table to make
aggregation and calcul
average percentage for example of t cell
across a different
different condition and that's possible
because i have
embedded into one export file the sample
tags
as well like the results of the
percentage of population that i could i
selected at the data
statistic export so it saves you a lot
of time because you have all the
information
in the sorry
in the spreadsheet that you can use for
further analysis
then obviously these tables you can use
for
third-party software to run statistical
analysis so
this is up to you the tool
then about the export illustration
element for publication quality
so for example here you can change
through the layout of the plot
you can change the size of the plot
that you you are showing so yeah you i
have taken the
huge the highest number of pixels per
plot
and then what i did is that i can
on the export button here i can
change the type of export perhaps if you
go in export option you have several
choice of what you can have
so i i've been minimalistic i only
wanted to have my plus basically
i saved it in in vector graphics
so that i can open it straight into
illustrator and then be able to edit my
text and then have my figure arrayed
already
for uh for the publication so that saves
you a lot of time
you don't need now to align and array
each individual plots everything is
ready positioned at the right place
from start so that's all for the
capabilities i wanted to show you so um
this these are again
different than regular um webinars you
might have
on cytobank where people focus on the
advanced analysis tool and machine
learning tool that are embedded within
the platform but
i think i think it's not only this so
you should i hope you
i could show you that through my my
presentation
that there are a lot more than just
machine learning tools into this
uh into this solution so as conclusion
um if uh we want to go back to basically
how we use
cytobank as if um so there are different
branches
there is the internal part as if so
where we can basically
have biologists that run analyze this
tool
either add safe on cytobank platform and
then
launch or upload the enrich fcs file
onto cytobank and do
metadata driven illustration store data
annotate
share that over a consortium member like
cell phaser
and then through the feedback we get
from this published data
slash illustration we can go another
round and maybe
do another type of analysis to actually
enrich
the experience of the data set that is
being stored on cytobank
the other part is the the development of
new methods and the
the validation by biologics by
experts of the method so it's not only
using metrics like f1 score but
really also using the expertise of
biologists
to to curate these new methods and and
see how they behave
so that bioinformatician and biologists
have cure
together a better understanding of the
method and and try to improve it
application and cytobank is a great
exchange platform for that within your
team
the finally um well here i've just
listed the few ones uh that
uh it could actually uh beneficial from
our use in test intensive use
of cytobank over this coved sanitary
crisis so
we were logged down but actually data
analysis were progressing thanks to
cytobank
so we could do data review fine we could
do reports we could generate
illustration
figures for papers and so on so that
that
did not stop us working basically thanks
to this cloud-based solution
so uh just few lines uh to sum up
uh i hope i showed you uh and convince
you that cytobank
is a platform that fulfilled by essence
these fair principles that are more and
more
asked in the field of data science so
your data should be
findable accessible interoperable
and be able to reuse the digital data
sets
if you if you if you actually combine
sharing data experiment
on cytobank using label tags that are
descriptive enough
so that people can find themselves
through what you actually did
uh you you really you really are into
this uh
fulfilling this principle now the since
uh
there have been a lot of work on uh by
by uh beckman culture and cytobank
uh uh to to improve uh the interface so
i i find it the new interface uh
really really nice because it's it
allows fast adoption by new
new people uh the experiment management
tool is
as you can as you have seen really
improved
the efficiency to access the data
and and and find really important
experiments
you've seen the use of illustration has
been um
has been referred so now it's very easy
to actually design
design illustration on multi-group
multi-samples
and interrogate part of the data set
like this
using like dynamic filters you can share
data very quickly as a click
and then um i i've mentioned that but
you can really do uh intel
this interactivity this change of
illustration and so on
you can really do that over tc so
because the server response space is
quite good
so it does not take long so that
illustrations are updated
and like this you can as i said solve
technical
questions and focus your tc time
with your collaborator on advanced
question and and building hypothesis
which
which is what we should really use this
time for
and finally uh yeah because we we no
need to perform offline secondary
analysis because we
we really really solved all these little
issues for the tc
so i'm now done i wanted to thanks uh
beckman culture for this opportunity to
present you
this capacity of cytobank and the way we
use
this algori this software solution
at this and also i wanted to thank the
people involved
in this work in one way and or or
another of what we
we do every day at this thank you very
much for your attention
and i'm happy to take questions
thank you dr lush for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
how do you deal with license management
and training at the level of a
consortium
okay so for the license management uh we
we basically use a cytobank that is
um called premium cytobank so all the
license management is actually not
not done by us but it's done by the
beckman sales rep which is
saving us a lot of time which is uh for
me i think it's really good
and then you have to plan in a in
advance um
the license cost in your project so like
for cell failure we
when we applied for the project we
applied for money for the license of
cytobank for
for one year this got extended for a
second year through due to the covet
situation
but basically i had really no issues
getting this extra money because
uh the the managers of the of the funds
they understood very well the advantage
of having a cytobank platform to
actually share data for the consortium
um we do guide new cytobank platform
adapters through for
face-to-face trainings could be through
a teleconference or
a desktop sharing but we also advise
them to ask
in parallel for support because beckman
has actually built a team
an application specialist team that can
help
you in in going through uh some
particular aspect of
cyto language it's very rich interface
so you cannot show everything
in in one webinar and finally uh or when
face-to-face action and finally there
are plenty of support uh material
videos webinars uh there is also a blog
that demonstrate the different
capabilities of the cytobank platform so
i really
encourage people to go and look at this
to train also themselves
on the new interface thank you dr lush
our next question is how do you manage
cross data validation of advanced
analysis with historical data
yeah so that's very important point
because when when you do these
collaborative projects
then uh you basically have to bring your
expertise and
so you you are bringing maybe you your
like for us it's it's um
high content parameter analysis and uh
um
in mass cytometry or spectral and flow
and are using algorithm advanced
algorithm methodologies but our partners
they are experts in the biology
they are experts they already did
preliminary experiments
um and they need to share the data and
that are the fundaments
of the collaborative work that we will
undertake so um
really using cytobank to
ask people to actually share their
historical data set on it is really
important
and then next also because we we have
now access for cytomax to this
historical dataset we can also
as i explained we can take the gating
strategy that people are using and
project onto this gating strategy
annotation or cluster analysis that
helps them
this time to actually better understand
this advanced methodologies
so it's because it you have a link with
historical data so it makes it very much
easier for your mind to understand
what's going on and what is being done
and also have um confidence
in the analysis that is driven in an
unsupervised manner
so engaging ml is the final one also
using this this
standard gating script you can
you can cross validate data
thank you dr lush our next question here
why um why use a cloud solution for data
analysis
instead of a desktop analysis tool
well um i i've just talked
about this uh a little bit um
when you're in a collaborative project
and you have several people
that are implicated you you i mean it's
it's
actually a limitation to work on your
workspace
because you you you you spend a lot of
time to
build power points uh and this is all
rigid because uh if you forgot to
address one
question or that your collaborator may
have
then you have to go back to your
workstation and and
drive a given illustration to solve that
as i've shown you on cytobank it could
be done on the fly
um then it it's also it's also very
very nice because i have my way to
analyze the data
and maybe that won't fit the way of my
collaborators but because i share that
asset
and illustration they can with their
license
actually re-analyze the same data set
their own way and then we can discuss
about
you know what overlaps and what not so
that we are
all at the same page so for me this is
this is a lot actually
more rigorous because like this you get
the expertise of several people
looking at the data set and and for
example in the in the self idea
consortium
we actually did build a very big rat
panel but we
don't have any knowledge about uh the
rat
mercury micrology i would say what type
of cell express what type of marker
and like this doing the analysis
collaboratively on the cloud solution
allows
our collaborators to to actually look at
the data themselves and provide
feedback which i think is really the
strength of the platform
final thing is that if you run machine
learning methods on a lot of events and
a lot of files
that takes a long time for your computer
to compute
and if you do that on cytobank basically
your computer can be used to do
something else because you are
using the server cpu to draw to do this
analysis
and not your machine
thank you dr lush our next question
what is the most interesting feature of
the cytobank platform in your views
compared to the others
so definitely the
using metadata tag to drive illustration
the way i can plug my metadata
describing my sample directly with the
fcs file using an excel spreadsheet
that's super convenient because you you
can have lots of meta tags
that you want to use and and in
different methods you have to add
keywords i mean this is quite laborious
here it's very easy to do
um then the capacity to export plenty of
descriptive statistics
called measures that can be used in
third party software is also really nice
so you don't have to
you don't have to compromise because you
you the possibility you have
is quite big quite large and
um i'm also i also like the features
that i have tried to highlight here
about data management level
um that i may have people that only
come and consume visualization some that
will have rights to actually clone
experiments and do their analysis on
their own
and edit graphics very quickly so this
is very
very nice to have that the work
basically can be shared
through this capacity
across the team thank you dr lush
and our last question for which type of
cytometry did you use this
uh the cytobank platform the most
we we've been early adopters of
our cytobank solution initially for my
cytometry dataset because we we had no
bioinformatician and that was at this
time pretty much
the only uh the only platform that
allowed us to do
efficient analysis of the new data data
type
i have to say now we are not restricted
because we actually do a lot of flow
experiments
uh loading them on cytobank also
spectral and
we also did some multi-omics data set
where we look at protein and
and gene at the same at the same time it
has to be there are some restrictions
it's limited to 800 variables but
this is nice because it allows again
biologists to be
at the field of the action and manage
drive their own analysis so
i would say it's not restricted now to
to mass
and i really think that it's a good
advantage for flow and spectral analysis
especially if you have lots of pies
the the what we have tested basically is
that the solution is compliant with
lots of different um conventional flow
cytometer so each time
fcs file format for a provider to
another one may be a bit different so
cytobank solution is very reliable and
it's basically a sort of swiss knife so
you can use that to look at whatever
data set
generated on this instrument uh yeah and
and to to to conclude on that uh i would
say that nowadays we mostly use cytobank
solution to
to project our data analysis
capabilities to our partners
due to this very easy uh easy sharing
capacity
uh like this um we we allow
our partners to have access to opsonize
the raw data set
through the illustration um interface of
the cytobank solution and uh last but
not least
within the sieve team um i often ask my
collaborators to share their
their just acquired data you know when
there is something really burning that
we never looked at uh so that i can have
a look at it too
in a remote manner i can even if i'm
traveling i can look at even
on my phone and then give suggestion or
advice from
from what i'm seeing there and that's uh
keeps you keep you in touch with uh with
the data that is being produced um
wherever you are so this is very very
nice capability too
thank you dr luch do you have any final
comments for our audience
well i hope i for this webinar i managed
to bring
that cytobank is actually a
more than just machine learning uh tool
it's uh it's it's really um will
bring allows you to efficiently dive
through your data sets
and and also communicate with you with
your colleagues
uh as either bioinformatician or
biologist of
different areas uh so that they you you
come across together faster and you can
drive
build hypothesis faster and then be
more productive basically in your in
your analysis
scheme i hope i managed to do that
well thank you again dr luch for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckman culture life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye